um i'm not perfect i've done a lot of
stupid stuff i've probably in
relationships and probably hurt people
um as everybody hurts people in
relationships
and uh but the best thing you can do is
forgive and uh it is a freeing free
moment i couldn't do it if i wasn't a
christian if i didn't believe in jesus
christ
um i mean that's a guy that was hanging
on a cross that did nothing
but he never asked for any money
he never um begged anybody for anything
he never forced his beliefs
he never forced what he was teaching on
anybody he gave everybody free will
and they did nothing but and they killed
him
they killed they killed a guy who did
nothing but want to be bring peace
and hope to the world
and they killed him and he looked right
at him and he said father forgive them
if he can do that so can i it makes me
think about
the way that the world is right now and
you're looking at
de-platforming cancel culture
things just things being taken out of
media and out of our reach
because of certain reasons and it's like
he got taken out based on just living
his life and not forcing anything but
just
you know preaching
uh truth preaching his feelings and like
today we're seeing this all over the
place people i mean i don't even know
where you stand on this but as a
comedian i felt like you guys are like
the last ones that get to make all the
jokes and say all the things where the
hell do you land on that do you all of a
sudden have to approach your shows
differently
well
before i get to that
uh he was the truth and he was shedding
light on darkness
and people don't want to have their
darkness uh light shined on their evil
deeds
and that's what's happening today
people don't want the truth being
being shown on the evilness that they're
doing and what they're trying to do
and so they will ban
any form of truth
because they don't want the truth
uncovered and that's a fact if you were
really here's the thing if you are
really truthful
you don't want anything bad because you
can defend what you're doing
if you're telling that if you if you're
telling the truth if you're an honest
person you're telling the truth you can
defend it because it's true and it's the
truth
if you're not telling the truth
they don't want to hear it so they will
do everything they can to get the truth
off of there because it's shining a
light on their deeds and they don't want
that shine
that was the same thing
well that's the same thing with christ
he was he was shining a light
on all of their fraudulent bs
and they didn't like it
you know so they were con
just real quick they were controlling
back and then the religious leaders the
pharisees and the uh
that
they were controlling the people with
religion with their religion
and jesus was shining a light
on what they were doing
uh
you know because religion's all man-made
rules following christ is his rules no
man-made rules so you have you noticed
with religion and with man-made rules
the goal post always changes you always
have different targets to hit
jesus has one target to hit one goal
post one target you're never confused
there it is what is it with man yeah
with man you're weak you're trying to
reach all kinds of these oh make sure
you just do this you got to do this so
you're not gonna
you know and make sure that your good
deeds out do your bad deeds that is
completely
not anything that jesus talked about at
all what's that what's that one truth
what's that one truth that you anchor
with i am the way the truth and the
light no man cometh the father but
through me
and they didn't like that and that's
what he said
um as far as uh
as far as
comedy goes with the times that we're
living in today um
it is tough
and uh
you know it's funny that bill maher i
have never
i'm one of those comics that like i like
all comedy comedy's hard and even though
a comic is
doing things that i don't agree with or
things that i would never do or say
i they have every right to do it and try
to find their own following it's called
capitalism it's called finding having a
doing what you do and having an audience
find you and likes you
you know if you don't like the comedian
if you think he's doing this or he's
hateful or then don't go see
don't go see him he's out of your life
don't try to ban him from being able to
do what he does
i mean it's ridiculous
um i feel bad for the comics coming up
today because they have this whole
different standard and they have people
that are running the entertainment
business
where if they don't like what you say
you're out of here
if they don't like what you do then
you're not going to get a break so you
better toe the line you better do jokes
that we find acceptable or you're not
going to be able to be comedian now the
comics that won't have a problem with
that are the ones that are already
established
the ones that already have a built-in
following where their audience tells
those people to go suck it
um
you know i feel bad for the up and
coming comics because they're going to
have a hard time with that
um but that there are those of us still
out there that do comedy the way comedy
was intended to be
uh you know god gave everybody a
different sense of humor we all have
certain senses of humor
it's a gift why do why why were we
created with a sense of humor and a
different type of sense of humor because
when we were created god knew
what our personalities were going to be
like what we were going to be like what
what we think what we think is funny to
one person isn't funny to another person
what one person thinks is funny another
person doesn't think is funny i don't
know how many times
i have been around people
that have kids that have like
uh that are that are
crippled or whatever
or or someone uh and and their dad or
their
will make it yeah you know
and they'll crack a joke about it you
know and you're thinking man why would
you crack a joke about you know why
because that's the way he deals with it
that's the way he can get through the
day
that's his sense of humor yeah he was he
was created with that sense of humor
because he was going to experience
situations where he would need that
sense of humor that's why we all have a
different sense of humor
to deal with certain
things
i have a friend who i have a friend who
got cancer and he ended up having
to have a ball cut off and he's like all
the jokes you can possibly make about
this would be wonderful so it's like you
know let's go have a ball but just one
you know like he wanted him all that was
just his sense of humor and then there's
somebody else like you said who has
something happen and it's literally it's
just taboo we don't talk about it and
um you know that's that there's enough
if you're yourself there's enough people
number one i think that resonates with
people when you're just kind of being
yourself whatever that is but there's
plenty of people out there in the world
there's like eight billion people you
know and or i'm trying to think uh what
i think biden said there was 350 million
people in the country but there's like
320 right so you know there's 320
million people just in this country so
you know there's enough people that will
pay attention to what you're doing and
your sense of humor will resonate with
even if it resonates with you know a
couple percent that's a lot of people
absolutely i mean and it's uh it's it's
good laughter is good